you start in a True Detective which I
think
explores some
darker aspects of human nature
what did you take from that
from that role that experience
philosophically psychologically
the freedom of of being on an island
he was such a singular
character and of a singular mind
and as you know it wasn't a a dance
party up there in his mind it was it was
some some heavy stuff
but also
existentially
for him always like
death would be a Deliverance for him
it'd also be a cop-out in a way it'd
also be
he was not not a man who was going to
give himself amnesty
and didn't allow it
from the rest of the world I wouldn't
give himself an out
and while living
in his head and heart and spirit was
more of a hell than
arguably dying
it was not no alternative that's not
negotiable for that man
and that's why he was such a that's why
he was the best detective that ever
walk the earth that's why he was such a
superhero in a way to have that singular
you don't go oh I wish I was him no but
you go like wow that Constitution that
Clarity of identity
talk about a measure in in a man's
Constitution he didn't allow anybody off
the hook especially himself
you wanted him to forgive a little bit
or give himself a little entity he
wanted him to like man it's Saturday bro
can you go on a date
he wanted him to like enjoy something
but
he was
connected to something in his DNA who's
who he was doing something much
more Baseline truth
and that's why we're such a good
detective so that but there's an island
as much as that company can be I said
earlier on that Amazon chip but it
wouldn't join the company
there's Parts I think that I maybe gave
to myself
to rust and Cole and also that Rustin
Kroll's giving back to me that are like
yeah when you're
when you want to pull the parachute
because you can't stand the company that
you're in McConaughey in your own mind
the socratic dialogue is driving you
freaking crazy
don't pull a parachute stick with it go
through it so you were able to walk
around with that tormented mind
of his tormented
I did I I didn't have very much patience
for mendacious talk
I didn't have as much patience for small
talk
I wasn't tormented
but the character was and you have to
embody him
so is that I mean does some of that
bleed over are you able to uh
separate the man you are from the
character
it's not
look am I able to separate yeah I came
home to my kids
and when they walk in the door and greet
me and go what'd you do today
and you got three kids under 10 years
old
you don't
tell them about the scene where you help
someone commit suicide it's just you
know so you you turn it into a parable
it actually I've always said this having
kids has made me a better actor and a
better Storyteller because I have to
parabolize certain things you know
um and tell it in ways as I go oh neat
you know
um
so
I did I go did I bring it home I didn't
bring torment did I bring introspection
into my own this character's for me and
I think this is true for a lot of
actors and actresses
we don't it's not a separation
if I've got I
we each have everyone
else
in US it's just seeing
diving into rust and gold knowing where
his mind and heart is from the hand of
Nick pizzolato who wrote the character
and wrote the whole series
understanding number one what the hell
am I saying what's he talking about then
going deeper into that well if that this
person really believes that what does
that say about how they
move then I'm going all of a sudden well
who is that in me what part of my left
brain is locked into that what part of
my Reptilian Brain is
latched on to that wherever this other
stuff is non-negotiable
then I just live in that and it's I
always taught like a 70s equalizer
remember the old that morons equalizers
you can you see as you move up your 500
hkz move up your 60 you just re you'd re
uh rebalance The Equalizer and we all
have so it's just going to those parts
of me where I'll turn up the volume
some parts of the base the treble on The
Equalizer and turn down other parts of
myself and I'll I'm not coming home
tormented
as rust and coal
am I coming home
seeing
torment where it should be seen
am I reading the news differently or
things coming out of the news and
catching my eye
as being
or lies or truth that it's just
hard and going yep yeah I'm seeing it
through a different lens but I'm seeing
my own life through a different lens
a lens that was opened up and an
aperture that was opened up through
rusting coal I mean the the the process
of being an actor an actress I guess is
a really interesting way to be a
philosopher of human nature
yeah I mean it's an incredible really in
it dive into the humanities yeah
yeah and all the ologies
and philosophy
and as I said I
going to going to
as I opened up that question like that
being on an island is a vacation
I am also conscious
for five months when I'm playing rusting
coal that
this this is an interesting fact I
I've never I was as strong spiritually
with my relationship with God
when I did True Detective as I've ever
been
what is that
okay which you would say wait a minute
in some ways that's a those are antonyms
no but but my I I
pretty sure pretty safely can say that
my own strength of spirit in my own
personal life Matthew's life there gave
me the confidence to go further away
deeper into the torture and deeper into
the
but it was still he was still always
going after truth that was the thing he
was not he was not not an evil man I
don't even know if you can call him a
non-believer but he was always going
after the truth and the truth Burns and
he would take the scar and get burned
for it
he'd die for it that something was
actually from
biblical about that you know and and so
but I've been I I don't think it's
coincidence that I was had so much
of diving into the depths of that uh
tortured
character
because I trusted that
when I go out I'll come up the other
side it's always like jumping in a pool
of water
and can you trust you'll come up the
other side and not
you know you go play a criminal you
trust you're not gonna come out the
other side of tyrant in real life
you just go ah God I got to go do that
came out and I'm still alive got all my
faculties I'm not in jail whatever it is
and so my own spirituality at that time
definitely I think gave me a certain
trust and confidence to go further into
the dark